this episode is sponsored by fabulous an
app that helps you start building your
ideal daily routine the first hundred
people who click on the link in the
description will get 25 off a fabulous
subscription
[Music]
the world is simply too vast for any
organism to find its way alone
there are too many turns too many
challenges inevitably
we all reach points in our lives where
we just need a little bit of help
and the micro cosmos is no exception the
world's earliest relationship builders
were microbes who through some
combination of chance and biology found
ways to use each other the word for this
of course is symbiosis and it is not
restricted to microbes you can watch
many a nature documentary and find many
examples of birds or fishes or large
mammals that form symbiotic
relationships perhaps one feeds on the
pests living on another and the other
provides shelter but there are many
symbiotic relationships that we can see
under the microscope as well one of the
most famous examples of symbiosis is
that of paramecium bursaria the
paramecium bursaria looks like an
ellipse with hairs poking out of it
which means that for the most part it
looks just like any other paramecium
but there is one big distinction the
paramecium bersaria is green and it is
green thanks to a whole host of algae
called chlorella that have taken up
residence inside its body because well
generations ago many generations ago a
paramecium ate some algae but instead of
digesting the algae the paramecium
just didn't and instead it started to
consume the products of the chlorellas
synthesis and then it passed that algae
on to the next generation and in return
the chlorella gets to use the paramecium
its former predator as a form of
protection and transportation
but scientists have separated the
bursaria from its algal symbians and it
turns out both of them can survive on
their own because each of the members of
the relationship benefits it's called
mutualism but because it is optional
it's called facultative so the
paramecium bursaria and its chlorella
are an example of facultative mutualism
so this all seems pretty simple and
straightforward symbiosis is a
biological exchange of goods and or
services an uncomplicated means of
partnering up to help survive
but relationships are always easier in
theory in practice they can be much more
complicated and difficult to understand
and for us as outsiders it takes
considerable work to decipher just what
kind of relationship microbes are
forming with each other james our master
of microscopes found this ciliate in
some mud and if you're wondering what
those fuzzy rod shapes are inside of it
those are prokaryotes stuffing up the
ciliate but besides knowing that those
are prokaryotes in there we can't really
tell much about what they're doing or
what their relationship is with their
ciliate host
do those prokaryotes help the ciliate
survive in the low oxygen environment of
the mud are they why we can't see any
food vacuoles in the ciliate are they
even helping each other at all or are
they parasitizing each other trying to
decipher all of that just by looking at
it would be like trying to describe the
complex dynamics of a family just by
looking at their portrait so to dive
deeper into what's going on james has
isolated and frozen some of these cells
in tiny tubes storing them for a future
day when he will be able to study them
more closely
now one of the disorienting aspects of
symbiosis at the microbial level is that
eukaryotic organisms are full of parts
that look a bit like other organisms and
that is not a coincidence in some cases
things like chloroplasts and
mitochondria are the product of
endosymbiosis
a prokaryote that got consumed so
completely by its symbiotic relationship
inside another organism that it has
become an organelle the process of
endosymbiosis is complete when the
endosymbiont has lost most of its genes
or given them over to its host
and that endosymbiotic history
complicates our human desire to
distinguish between an organelle and an
organism but fortunately we do have
molecular tools that allow us to
investigate
[Music]
[Music]
further this diatom epithelia gibba has
had at least two distinct things noted
about it one is its unusual capacity to
convert extremely stable but
biologically useless diatomic nitrogen
into actually useful nitrogen compounds
we call this nitrogen fixing and the
other thing that people have noted about
it is the round bits that appear like
beady bubbles inside of it when
scientists looked closer they found that
the round bodies had a double membrane
around them suggesting that they might
be another organism living inside the
diatom so they spun the diatoms and
treated them with chemicals to extract
these mystery parts and studied the
genes inside them ultimately finding
that the diatom was occupied by
cyanobacteria
these cyanobacteria it turns out are
responsible for the diatoms ability to
fix nitrogen but when it comes to the
question of organelle versus organism
well this cyanobacteria
is kind of both
it doesn't appear to perform
photosynthesis in the diatom its main
function is to fix nitrogen but to enter
into that relationship with its host
cyanobacteria had to change its own
nitrogen fixation schedule to max the
diatoms daily photosynthetic activities
the extent of the cyanobacteria's
adaptation to its host and the fact that
it is passed on from generation to
generation of diatoms suggests that
while those cyanobacteria might still be
their own cells they may be on their way
to becoming an organelle
fully endosymbiosed into a piece of
epithelia gibba
and other mysteries remain even when
they seem initially clear-cut this
luxoty's rostrum is a rare find for us
but it's also quite distinctive because
it bears not one but two different types
of algae in it and now that might seem
like yet another version of the
paramecium bursaria and chlorella
relationship we saw earlier we have a
large ciliate occupied by algae
combining their respective bodies and
machinery to supply different forms of
nutrition to each other that neither
would get on its own there's nothing
weird about this right nothing startling
nothing extraordinarily strange except
that luxoty's rostrum are also full of
pigments to avoid light because they
don't like light they practically melt
when they're exposed to light and that's
a problem for algae because light is
kind of part of their thing like it's an
important part of photosynthesis so how
do they survive together why are they
doing this
we don't know
there must have been some kind of
compromise
the nature of that compromise remains
unknown to us
maybe they're just like that couple who
seem deeply incompatible and yet somehow
they need each other and they make it
work
at least that's how it looks from the
outside but in the future generations of
loxodies from now maybe this
relationship will look different and
perhaps like every other relationship it
will evolve helping both organisms
confront new challenges that the world
will inevitably throw at them
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to fabulous for sponsoring
this episode every year most people set
new year's resolutions but around 80
percent of those will get abandoned in
just the first two months
the best way to succeed with your
resolutions is to transform them into
tiny habits and stick to them thanks to
the fabulous app
developed by behavioral scientists at
duke university fabulous has guided
journeys for common resolutions like
exercising more improving your sleep and
eating healthier it's the number one
self-care and habit-forming app in the
app store with over 20 million users and
it can help you whether you're looking
for ways to stay focused at work or you
just need a reminder to take a break
once in a while to stretch and drink
some water there's no shortcut to
changing habits with your resolution
this year consider a proven affordable
sustainable long-term approach to
changing your life one that builds on
your successes the app is 100
personalized to your goals and you can
start building your ideal daily routine
today and the first hundred people to
click on the link in the description
will get 25 off a fabulous subscription
you want to talk about a symbiotic
relationship how about the one that we
have with the people whose names are on
the screen right now they are our
patreon patrons they want there to be
good educational interesting chill
microscope content on the internet and
we want to make it but we need their
support and so that relationship has
come together and what is the result
this video and all of the other videos
on this channel if you want to be one of
these people who make it possible for us
to do this and also get access to some
pretty cool perks you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us i bet you i bet you can find a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
you